hi my name is Sid Srinivasan I'm a
professor at the robotics Institute at
Carnegie Mellon University I work on
robots physically interacting with the
world picking up objects diffusing bombs
it's really exciting it allows me to try
and understand not just how robots do
these tasks but also try and understand
how we perform these tasks we take
manipulation physically interacting with
the world for granted but really it's
the integral of so many hundreds of
thousands of years of our own evolution
that enables us to so effortlessly pick
up a coffee mug off of a table and we're
trying to teach robots that instinct
that ability to be able to understand
what the world looks like but not just
understand passively what the world
looks like but actively physically
interact with it
herb stands for home exploring robot
Butler it's a robot that has two arms on
a Segway base that we've been building
since 2005 and he is our platform for
autonomy we're trying to build robots
that can be completely autonomous and
wander around in your home or your
office or in a disaster rescue scenario
and perform complex manipulation tasks
with and around people so what we're
doing is we're developing machine
learning algorithms that can look at you
and understand your state understand
whether you're happy or sad and also
understand your intentions as I move my
arm you are running prediction
algorithms that are trying to predict
what my goals are what my intentions are
and it is those prediction algorithms
that are helping us to collaborate
seamlessly think about the time when you
work in a kitchen with someone it's a
delicate dance it's a delicate dance of
moving around them but there's also a
delicate dance of anticipating what
they're going to do or what they're
trying to do and completing the task for
them and I want humans and robots to be
able to perform that dance every day in
our homes in our daily lives and that is
what will enable seamless human robot
collaboration we have over six million
people in the United States were in need
of care
and I think it's a both moral and civic
responsibility to make sure that we can
build technology that is not just useful
and functional but actually can provide
care for people in need I think one of
the really exciting parts about robotics
is that we not only get to develop the
theory and write the algorithms but also
put them on real systems that go and
have impact on real people I'm
collaborating with the Rehabilitation
Institute of Chicago where we're working
with patients with high spinal cord
injuries paraplegics quadriplegics and a
lot of these patients are kids teenagers
were bungee jumpers and cave divers and
broke their spine the ability to work
closely with them to understand what
their challenges are and the potential
that we can actually in our lifetimes
develop technology that can help them is
extremely rewarding and extremely
challenging but really exciting